welcome everybody we are here once again
for a Donald Trump coronavirus press
briefing during which we will no doubt
hear lies and distortions from Donald
Trump but hopefully we will get some
facts and actual data from some of the
doctors who hopefully are on the stage
some of you may notice by the way I am
wearing my data male t-shirt they it
came in as you can see hold on there it
is I do have it now and it's beautifully
constructed 100% cotton just an amazing
amazing shirt and I know that they are
starting to be delivered to a lot of
different people who have ordered them
and there is still time for you to grab
one very very very exciting stuff we
have sort of increasingly there's kind
of two realities that we have in the
United States and so there's one reality
in the United States which is the one
around the world which is the cases are
increasing dramatically I posted today
to my Twitter page as you might see here
where was this here it is case numbers
it took months to get our first hundred
thousand cases it took 12 days to get
the second hundred thousand cases it
took only three days to get to the third
and fourth hundred thousand cases it
took only two days to get to five
hundred thousand and as we speak
we are already up to five hundred and
twenty five thousand in that context
Donald Trump wants to start opening it
up and letting a rip now for people who
don't know about where let er rip comes
from Anthony foul she mentioned it hold
on about she let rip where is it here it
is this is the origin where Anthony foul
she sort of when they started thinking
about this idea Anthony foul she's the
one who equated just ignoring all social
distancing and quote letting her rip
this is where it came from take a listen
and we'll we'll move up a little bit
here
OOP and I'm sorry I don't actually have
that hooked up correctly I had speakers
turned on let me get back into our
system there we go okay now we should be
able to hear it multiple actions
exponentially
it's the difference between life yeah I
agree with it but I think I'd like to
have Anthony answer that because to be
honest that's what he does and he we had
a lot of a lot of very talented people
telling us this what they like it we
should do it
Thank You mr. president first of all I
think that's a false equivalency to
compare traffic accidents with I mean
that's totally way out that's really a
false equivalency when you have
something that is new and it's emerging
and you really can't predict totally the
impact that's gonna have and you take a
look at what's gone on in China and you
see what's going on right now right now
in Italy and what's happening in New
York City I don't think with any moral
conscience you could say why don't we
just let it rip and heroness so letting
it rip oh and let the X percent of the
people die I don't understand that
reasoning right well that's what Trump
now wants to do and that's why there's
more and more speculation that we made
that Anthony thought you mean it may not
be around that much longer five hundred
and twenty-five thousand known global
cases makes the real likely number
somewhere between two and five million
in the United States another 13 thousand
cases today we are now number one you
know Trump wants to make America great
again we're number one in a lot of bad
things we're number one in total cases
of course that's not adjusted to the
population of course this is also not
the real number we're having the most
new cases daily we don't yet have the
most deaths but I would not be surprised
if we if we start going in that
direction and within the United States
of course it's it's still regionalised
to some degree I mean New York has
38,000 of the 81 thousand cases but New
Jersey now is having numbers that are
starting to rival New York in terms of
new case numbers half of that California
Michigan having big gains here in
Massachusetts we picked up 600 new cases
today this is hard to imagine a worse
time to think about opening it up and
letting it rip so we'll see and you know
Trump Trump essentially in a way Trump
knows it because in the last few days of
press conferences there's no discussions
of case numbers there's no discussions
of the death toll it's all about stocks
checks companies
you know unemployment benefits
ventilators that he says GM is
manufacturing but they're not so this is
this is very quickly getting to be you
know it didn't start in the United
States but Trump was late to begin with
now it's actually getting to the point
where it may get the worst here than it
has been anywhere and it's growing
exponentially and it's it's a complete
and total mess welcome on Twitch YouTube
Facebook and Twitter we are a few
minutes maybe yesterday they were about
45 minutes late starting of course
anybody who wants to support the streams
which have been daily consider yourself
invited to grab a membership on my
website at join pakman.com we we had a
bit of a delayed effect but we are now
getting hit very hard from people
understandably having to tighten their
belts we're gonna look at unemployment
numbers in a second a lot of people
furloughed losing jobs so we're gonna
the next few months will be very very
tough for us so if you aren't I don't
want your last two dollars right but if
you are in the in the part of our
audience that can afford to support the
work we do a membership for a couple of
bucks a month on my website is very much
appreciated at join pakman.com okay
let's get into let's get into some of
the super chats that are coming in Oh
first let me say thanks to be Swizzle 24
for the twitch subscription and also for
the cheer I appreciate both of those
also thanks to Berger means on twitch
and if you're watching on YouTube make
sure to hit that like button and that's
a subscribe button both really do a lot
for us it's free the buttons are drop
the buttons very much free super chats
are coming in Paul JM says quick
question the drugs they sent to New York
is it going to be used in a clinical
trial or directly on patients love the
show Trump lies all the time so we don't
know the drug sent to New York are part
there it's one of four treatment
modalities
that's better part of a clinical trial
it seems in addition Trump just had a
whole bunch sent maybe for compassionate
use we don't know what's going I mean
this is the whole point we don't we
don't know what the hell's going on
a Beezus says you have disgustingly
hairy arms shave your triceps are you
crazy there's I mean that this is are
you nuts I'm gonna start shaving my arms
everything I have going on I'm gonna
start shaving arms it's a toxic idea
never Mikayla McGonagall says thanks for
me by the way I you know that this is
called Semitic hair what can I do about
it
Mikayla McGonagall says thanks for
making these so bearable to watch
appreciate everything you do David keep
it up Thank You Mikayla Thank You
Mikayla Collin Schmidt says anyone who
voted for Donald Trump should get him a
primary care physician since they trust
him to make medical decisions should get
him as a primary care physician maybe
you meant Donna William says thank you
David I don't watch these life vests
without you yeah don't remember the visa
commercials don't leave home without it
don't watch Trump press conferences
without some assistance I think that
that's very good advice alien peace says
the three-month shutdown didn't destroy
China's economy why should it destroy
the US economy China is booming right
now I don't know if China's booming I'm
not up to speed and and also would they
tell us the truth would they even give
us the right information I don't know
about that but there's no question that
if we just decided hey all 50 governors
were shutting it down for two full
months two and a half three maybe three
full months we would already be close to
a month in had we started when it made
sense by the way we would survive of
course of course we would survive
there's no question about it okay let me
say a huge thank you this is just like a
brutally huge thank you to Jayson Bryden
Jason is new member number one today at
join pakman.com Jason you're the man
very much appreciate it Jason Bryden has
signed up and also David van Ripper it's
probably a Van Riper but I find van
Ripper to be more interesting David Van
Riper is new member number two today at
join pakman.com also very much
appreciate your support we are waiting
for Donald Trump and hopefully some
doctors and people who know stuff at the
top of the hour I hopefully they're not
late today because I have a hard out
6:30 p.m. Eastern Time which is in 90
minutes yesterday was very short but
they were late sometimes they're long
but on time sometimes they're long but
late nobody really knows a couple other
things to tell you about let's see here
what did I want to show you oh okay
here's Mitch McConnell Mitch McConnell
earlier today was asked a very good
question by a reporter female reporter
his answer to her do you work here do
you work here take a listen
understanding that of course this is a
crisis and time is of the essence this
vote began and the public had not yet
seen the bill lobbyists had seen the
bill and none of the debate had been
held in public there is virtually no
public debate on what looks to be the
largest bill in American history can you
explain why that was and should the
public have had more time to understand
what this bill is that is meant to help
them the guy who is solely responsible
for a 10-day delay on this nonsense
asking do you work here do you work here
incredible okay we do have now have live
video from inside the room another clip
I wanted to play for you today this is
from Fox and Friends now if you have
these concentric circles or maybe will
turn down the audio there so we can
listen to this if you think about sort
of like toxic ideology and then you've
got like trumpism is within that and
then you've got Fox News Fox and Friends
is like very much at the top of the were
absolute worst
here's Ainsley Earhardt complaining
about how listen she's staying outside
the city but she's got an apartment in
the city and she needs to you know she's
got blouses she needs to return and a
little out of that okay take a look it's
interesting too you know we're talking
about this and every day we're talking
about different topics because we're
moving in
hopefully the direction of getting to
where China is now ours okay let's stop
it already they're pretending like we've
turned the corner China and South Korea
did things that were not doing South
Korea tested huge portions of the
population contact tracing quarantine
everybody who test positive even
asymptomatic
China had an authoritarian lockdown for
two months they're now acting like we're
kind of in the same we're starting to go
and we're not going in that direction
but regardless let's continue yes now
I'm and just getting some improvement
but I was thinking you know we all I
live in the city you can't go back to
the say you can but I don't want to
because I don't want to be around the
area that's infected the most huh
but I'm thinking like all the bills that
are stacking up at my apartment you know
we've got to think about that kind of
thing if you bought clothing before all
of this happen if you were never so
millionaire Fox News host working out of
her second home or who knows where is
worried that some of her bills at her
New York apartment might be late which
of course she could be paying online
anyway you know three million people
filed for unemployment last week Ainsley
I hate to break it to you return it our
store is gonna get a you know waive that
30-day period you might have a blouse
guys she might have a blouse that if she
doesn't bring back to Express
she may not be able to exchange it for
the right size do you understand what's
going on here and get your money back if
you need to return something these are
all the things people are staying home
women I mean y'all don't think about
this guy's but and you know this is not
a priority but we have to get their hair
done your I saw someone tweet out you're
gonna see what color are real hair is
because our roots are gonna grow in
right women all my friends are saying
you know this is not a priority people
are dying and I realize that but they
can't get their nails done you know
businesses are closed everywhere its job
we're in priority mode right now it's
pharmacies and it is grocery stores then
occasionally places people are going
what is that how I'm trying to
understand how that acts she says
instead of saying I realized that she
says I realized that is that the accent
I realized that I just I'm not I never
have a good grasp it sounds like
southeastern but not Texas am i
somewhere in the ballpark with it anyway
very very bad very very bad stuff that's
that's going on there that was not a
parody I know that you might have
thought that that was like an SNL skit
that was actually Fox News this morning
let me say thank you to Nick Lex Nick
Lex is new member number three today at
join pakman.com Nick thank you so much
really appreciate everybody who's been
supporting the streams especially as
we're
taking a lot of hits a lot of
cancellations because of what's going on
I very much appreciate everybody who's
been signing up and of course if you've
just entered the YouTube stream remember
to hit that subscribe button and hit
that like button this stuff is free and
it really does me a solid when you do it
if people missed last night's David
Pakman show coronavirus quarantine chess
tournament I did not win
we had cheaters cut so this is this is
crazy I did a chess tournament yesterday
for viewers of the show whoever wants to
play
I was hoping for fifty participants all
right 500 people played in my chess
tournament yesterday I came in around a
hundred and thirtieth out of 500 I'm not
that good and it was no surprise my
chess teacher Eric Rosen international
master Eric Rosen appeared and he won
but people cheated and got caught okay
there were people who were identified as
cheating and major controversy major
major controversy can you imagine
cheating in the David Pakman show chess
tournament like I mean is that that's
what people's lives are down to at this
point it's absolutely insane
anyway it was it was great turnout great
turnout and we may do it monthly I don't
know people seem to like it and it was
just good to do something having nothing
to do with with with coronavirus how do
you cheat people are asking I'm not even
gonna tell you that's it's I I love that
not everybody knows how to cheat and I'm
certainly not going to tell you how to
do it okay let's see here sexy swag has
become a soy boy level YouTube member
sceeto she
nakai yo bro says even after accepting
this situation it still gets me
genuinely scared sometimes is this
normal yeah I I every once in a while
especially when I look at the numbers I
will start to look at these numbers and
the completely you know vertical
increase that we are now experiencing
and it is very scary I mean look at look
at this it's almost off the screen it
this is going up so quickly
iota Li understand that I share that
feeling
lethal B says do you believe Oh hold on
lethal B says where was that do you
believe the numbers coming out of China
I really don't know I truly don't know
WH Oh officials say they do believe them
so you know that's something a CSIS
already have a membership so here's five
bucks just because I think you're cool
thanks AC Charlie says how did chess go
did you win okay I just address that
Twinkle Twinkle says Jeffrey Epstein
didn't kill himself
Alexander Salinas is when should I
expect my Corona check thanks David
three weeks I have video I mean while
we're here we might as well look at the
video here's a Steven minuchin talking
about this this morning on CNBC how is
Treasury Secretary Steven ocean first
mr. secretary congratulations on the
record time you put this together
quickly versus two thousand seven two
thousand nine when will the checks be in
the mail
well Jim first of all thanks for having
me back and I want to thank the Senate
for their swift action people literally
the Senate delayed it unnecessarily ten
days worked round the clock for five
days visit with President and I and
others couldn't be more pleased with the
absolute unanimous support you couldn't
be more pleased well on a bipartisan
basis to get this done in regards to the
checks I announced yesterday from the
White House press conference first of
all most of these will be direct
deposits so we call them checks in the
mail but mostly be direct deposits it'll
be within three weeks we are determined
to get money in people's pocket
immediately so that will be within three
weeks so a couple things on that and I
had a tweet about this earlier as well
where are my tweets here there so first
of all within three weeks maybe if they
get it passed soon but more importantly
that only applies to the group of people
who qualify filed their taxes in 2018 or
2019 got a refund and got the refund via
direct deposit you have to meet all
those requirements in order to get the
direct deposit in three weeks
otherwise it could be three to five
weeks beyond that so if there's no delay
half of the recipients are looking at
six to eight weeks if not longer that's
two months or longer now consider the
incongruity of what's going on we on the
one hand we have many governor's
extending stay home orders into April or
past April into May here in
Massachusetts schools are now closed
until early May Trump says we're winning
and he wants to open open up and let it
rip on April 12th the most optimistic
date were half of the country would get
their checks would not be until after
the economy will be back open according
to Trump the other half aren't going to
get their checks until optimistically
may 7th and then meanwhile cases and
deaths continue to explode while Trump
doesn't even mention them during these
press briefings how does the timing of
any of this stuff make sense like what
on what planet does any of what's going
on make sense it's absolutely ludicrous
let me say thank you to Jacob Nylund
Jacob Nylund his new member number four
today at join pakman.com Alex never is
new member number five today at join
pakman.com I see a lot of people saying
David you're wearing a t-shirt this is
the beta I'm sorry this is the data male
t-shirt now I'm doing it this is the
data male t-shirt available on my
website I'll show it to you hold on okay
available in multiple colors it's all
it's fresh out of the box so it's still
looking it's looking a little odd but
this is the the viewer designed data
male t-shirt that we are selling that
will sell the beta male t-shirts at some
point in the future for now we are only
selling data male t-shirts and I think
we've sent them to eight or nine
countries so far or something like that
very it's it's very quickly rivaling the
black coffee mug as the most popular
item in my online store welcome if
you're joining us on twitch twitch now I
want to say thanks to Z Lix for
subscribing with prime Adam Punk has
sent some bits ancient Nikolas has also
subscribed with prime which I appreciate
yeah the next t-shirt is going to be
theta male that's actually that would be
a good one and it can just be it'll just
be the the Greek letter
theda we don't even have to spell it out
that's kind of a cool idea too okay
other super chats coming in remember if
you're watching on YouTube hit that like
button hit that subscribe button
Lee Douglas says thank you for covering
the briefings you make the lies
tolerable I'm a site member and watch
all your streams and daily show we love
you David
Thank You Lee love you too really
appreciate the support Beezus says not
your forearm forearms your triceps and
biceps can you imagine if what I decide
to do is shave my biceps why on earth
would I do that plus then if I go to the
beach and take my shirt off and my
forearms are hairy and the rest of my
arm is shaved
I don't know much about shaving shaving
arms because I've never done it but it
sounds like that would be weird that
sounds like it would be very very weird
thanks to Michael cappellas for grabbing
a youtube membership tika says
furloughed but doing okay appreciate the
streams Thank You ty Iike a user who
goes by the name I fart magic how is GM
making anything if they're shut down oh
you're thinking you're thinking too
logically that doesn't uh that that's
not how Trump thinks Alexander Jones
says how would a debate against ben
shapiro go for you I don't know there's
actually a pretty funny clip let me see
if I can find it this is a funny thing
this is a really old thing Packman ben
shapiro see if i can find it
yeah there's a really funny moment from
this interview that I did I'm just
trying to find that one moment but it
doesn't look like I can me let's see if
I can find it here where exactly was
that I think it's right around here
let's take a look later in that same
show after I left he admitted it that if
he had his druthers he would get rid of
all guns on American soil yeah the only
thing is that Justice Antonin Scalia has
said a lot of the same things that Piers
Morgan has said I think that we get into
a we get a little muddled when we talk
about exactly what the founders intended
because let's be honest everything was
very different when the founders bro
that second amendment so I don't know
that just saying we have I don't I don't
like to focus on the commas in the
second amendment this is so to speak I
don't think that's true though I think
that the second amendment is largely
about human nature and the fact is that
we have seen tyranny on American soil I
mean we have together spot I'm looking
for and I guess maybe it's later let me
see here
let's just check it out and see if it's
here and on own its restriction on what
the state can do and what it says that
the state can do is it says the state is
not allowed to infringe your right to
bear arms now the question becomes what
is the definition of arm right so I know
yeah yeah I think most likely this is
interesting because we could probably go
on 20 more minutes and we probably
wouldn't come to an agreement on this
but I think this is really we were doing
fine agreeing on a lot of stuff until we
got to this and I think this is where a
lot of people are getting lost also I
think it's a very simple argument from
my point of view and that is the people
if they have the right to bear arms in
order to prevent tyranny then that that
goes for arms to prevents it that goes
to the the ultimate limit of that is the
arms necessary to prevent the basically
you can own any arm that is necessary to
necessary not rather than to to prevent
tyranny because in a way coats so that's
the moment that a lot of people like
let's just let's just listen to that one
more time because I don't I'm trying to
follow the army the Second Amendment
doesn't prevent you from doing anything
I mean the First Amendment doesn't
prevent you from doing anything okay
with the states drawing the lines on
what guns you can have but not the
federal government it's a restriction on
government right I mean the Second
Amendment is not creating it as a
restriction on individual it's not a law
about what guns you can and cannot own
it's restriction on what the state can
do and what it says that the state can
do is it says the state is not allowed
to infringe your right to bear arms now
that the question becomes what is the
definition of arm right so I know yeah
yeah yeah I think most likely this is
interesting because we could probably go
on 20 more minutes and we probably
wouldn't come to an agreement on this
but I think this is really we were doing
fine agreement wasn't really and I know
this is where a lot of people are
getting lost also I think it's a very
simple argument from my point of view
listening now the people if they have
the right to bear arms in order to
prevent tyranny then that that goes for
arms to prevents it that goes to the the
the ultimate limit of that is the arms
necessary to prevent the basically you
can own any arm that is necessary to
necessary not rather than to to prevent
tyranny well this isn't because I'm just
not understanding it I'll tell you I
just don't I don't really know exactly
what he's talking about there but that
anyway that's that's a popular that's
probably the most the most widely shared
moment from my interview with with ben
shapiro back in the day let me say thank
you to karmic brutality gaming as well
as IM kombu bear and hackle Hackley
hackle for the twitch subscriptions let
me also say thanks to chip Lamphere chip
Lanfear is new member number six today
at join pakman.com thanks chip I really
do appreciate your support very very
much okay Colin Schmidt says thank you
David that's what I meant facepalm okay
Eric Hendrickson says us more cases than
China with a population of 1.5 billion
ugly ugly stuff and the real number is
probably higher because we are still not
really testing Dex dark says thanks for
all of the coverage and staying
level-headed through all of this helps a
ton love from California the tidal wave
is coming that too low
sends a super chat Ian says David Plus
no haircut for months equals disaster
yeah even the side of my hair I'm almost
starting to get like pay us and I'm not
even an Orthodox Jew but it's like
naturally growing into that it's really
really weird and as you can see it's
like it's not good it's very very much
not good I think it almost is going like
a foot up right now it's gonna be a
while unfortunately yeah it's just I
don't even get it I actually think that
there's probably some kind of physics
class in what's going on here but
probably exceeds the scope of my
knowledge of mechanical physics okay if
you're just joining us they are of
course 18 minutes late starting this
press conference and we are wondering if
it'll happen soon if you are joining me
on YouTube I would love it if you hit
the like button and the subscribe button
both are really really use
well and doesn't cost anything and
really does a lot to help the streams I
also want to say say thank you and
welcome to Jacob Elka Jacobs new member
number seven seven seven seven at join
pakman.com lucky sevens as no one I know
ever says Maria Amaro has grabbed a
youtube membership make it simple says
please arm-wrestle ben shapiro
or kyle their week you know i think
during the times of physical distancing
that's unlikely to happen alexander
alexander jones says how would a debate
go against steven crowder go that is
that the comedian that came up during my
Joe Rogan appearance I barely even know
who that is I don't know this is gonna
be good I know it says I'm American my
wife is a German green card holder as
are my kids any idea whether will get
full support for them too or only $1,200
I don't know the answer to that I don't
know the answer to that
cooking with kale says I have a
life-saving kovat gravity hookah
ventilator that can be bought from Home
Depot and electronics hobby store
instruction in pandemic cookbook ok I've
no clue whether that's an inside joke or
something serious I don't know
gunner Emma son has grabbed a YouTube
membership ragu Auriga says Ainsley
Earhardt doesn't surprise me my college
is a my colleague is a boomer trump
estancia read about getting her nails
done than the pandemic yikes
Jim Griffin has grabbed the soy boy
membership unknown prodigy says I quit
because I played a cheater it was
obvious yeah there were unfortunately
some cheaters yesterday during the
during the chess tournament Shan Rose
says greetings from Holland keep up the
great work
cat cookie and cat cat 66 both grab
YouTube subscriptions Brian Strait says
don't you find this to be a complete and
total waste of time not really I mean I
you know I'm interested in seeing what
the narrative is from the from the White
House I'm interested in hearing what
questions the reporters asked very often
things we talked about like five days
later they make their way into the
briefings not through me
just like corporate media catches up
with what's being discussed on
independent media and you know I get to
hear from from you guys and figure out
what
what's on your mind which I also very
very much enjoy doing so I don't think
it's a waste of time
Aaron Nance has grabbed a twitch Prime
subscription says when do you think
mainstream media will report that the US
has beat China in Italy for most
positive and active cases of the
coronavirus
I would assume tonight but I barely
watch corporate media so I don't know
thanks to dragon fly back home Tara D
wisdoms CND good old sport as well as
Lyceus old man beef and the anonymous
gift er who gifted a sub to Trump for
president oh boy
very much appreciate all of those all of
those subscriptions the vegan villain s
says I looked and behold a national and
he who sat on it had the name of willful
ignorance joking aside thanks for
keeping us sane David thank you for the
for the support
Alvaro bazan says PPN are laid off all
part-time employees we need Bernie
Beatty says I've come to rely on you for
level-headed commentary that's just
snarky enough to be entertaining without
being petty or clickbait II thank you I
love that I love that assessment
Daniel Rivera has released the full
Pakman Tournament report hashtag chess
skate yeah so I I did a a post-mortem of
the chess tournament on today's bonus
show so anyone who gets a membership on
my website listen to today's bonus show
and you will hear the full breakdown as
well as some game analysis from last
night's tournament Armando Salazar has
signed up at join pakman.com and his new
member number 8 of 25 Thank You Armando
very much appreciate your support as we
wait for yet another press briefing
blake feely says canada is giving for $4
four thousand for three months for comma
zero zero is there a missing zero or is
that incorrect comma $400 for three
months i don't know
Judis andrade sends a dollar super chat
Mike Valverde says should major Network
stop airing these conferences here's
what I said yesterday about that
networks should air them but fact check
in real-time like actually devote some
resources to fact-checking in real-time
otherwise I don't know I then it's less
of a I think they should be aired in
fact checked that's that's what I try to
do thanks to Peter cat Borg for signing
up on YouTube andronik Massey Massey
says I saw someone watching your show on
their TV today no like you walked
outside someone's house and inside my
face was on the TV that's interesting
Ryan boys Claire says you can do the
sign for mail as well
after theta theta mail that's
interesting that's not a bad t-shirt tat
Kat says you're a voice of reason in a
time of insanity thank you
waffles you're awful says here's your
daily money in crippled 50 character
sentences Thank You Awful's Saira della
Reve says I'm diggin the hairstyle arm
hair is cool yeah I I do have a lot of
thick Semitic arm hair can't do much
about him just the way it is my friends
just the way it is let's see here looks
like we're getting closer as we now have
close to all of the seats that will be
full will be full I'll remind you if
you're just joining us we are also now
streaming on Facebook as well as Twitter
want to say welcome to the folks
watching on Facebook Facebook's so
unpredictable sometimes we'll have 1500
people watch on Facebook and then
sometimes we have just a few hundred
like right now I really don't know what
it is that triggers for lack of a better
term people to watch on Facebook and
remember we do have a goal of 25 website
members we're at 8 which is nothing to
sneeze at just shy of a third but
consider yourself invited to grab a
membership at join pakman.com people
asking whether dr. Burks will get a
chance to speak today or Fowey
you never know you just never know
Thackeray Monroe says thoughts on Star
Trek my favorite TV franchise I know
nothing about Star Trek I've seen the
two new - if there are only two I've
seen both or two of the new Star Trek
movies and otherwise I just know very
very little about Star Trek sim Rick
says David's arms and his attitude
against Shaving are the most alpha data
mail thing I've ever seen
I just have been forgetting to shave
like every day is the same and it's I'm
just not really shaving I don't know
what's the point at this point in time I
might actually I was thinking about
trying to do some fundraiser where like
by next week if I don't shave it's gonna
be a pretty grim situation maybe I do
something there must be some way to turn
this into some kind of fundraiser I
don't know what it would be like every
day we add a dollar and if that donation
is met then I keep not shaving or
something like that I don't really know
yeah this is this is a year of growth
it's been a year since I shaved for
people who are asking no it this is this
is actually this is a week to be
perfectly frank this is a week there's
dr. Burks dr. Anthony Fauci looking spry
at 79 very very spry guy dr. Burks
standing almost as far as humanly
possible from from doctor foul Chi
they're very interesting let me say
thank you to Payton Evans Peyton Evans
is new member number nine today at join
pakman.com Thank You Peyton very much
appreciate that support and remember we
are not means testing the coupon code
the coupon code 2020 now is 66% off
absolutely no means testing it's done
you decide whether you want the discount
or not we we don't get involved in it
crypto monkey says thank you for being a
voice for a sane America love from
Australia here is Donald Trump followed
by Mike Pence
you very much thank you beautiful day
very good what you're doing look at all
those empty seats let me see if it's
louder on this feed very good what
you're doing look at all those empty
seats I guess this is a little out in it
like that oh boy
well how the world has changed how the
world has changed right but it's gonna
end up being better than ever
I want to thank you very much for being
here and I'd like to update you and the
steps we're taking on our ongoing fight
to defeat the virus this morning at 7:55
I spoke to the leaders of the g20 had a
great meeting and we have a lot of
different ideas a lot of good ideas
we're working together the leaders
gathered virtually around the world to
discuss the whole subject of the problem
that right now 151 nations have got we
had President
Alberto Fernandez of Argentina prime
minister Scott Morrison of Australia
President garibaldi Naro of Brazil chair
like German astir justin trudeau of
Canada president G of China President
Emmanuel macron of France Chancellor
Angela Merkel of Germany
Prime Minister Modi of India president
Widodo of Indonesia Prime Minister
Giuseppe Conte of Italy Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe a of Japan congratulations to
Japan are making a great decision when
the Olympics are gonna make it next year
2021
what on earth President Andres Manuel
Lopez Obrador
Paulo I want to thank the President of
Mexico for having done such a great job
with respect to the military we have
27,000 Mexican soldiers on our son
border and very few people are getting
through I can tell you that we got to
keep it that way and we have a great
relationship with Mexico now President
Putin of Russia King Salman of Saudi
Arabia president Ram poza
of South Africa you know they could just
release of as you know a country that we
spend a lot of time in South Korea we're
working very hard on that Prime Minister
Sanchez of Spain president Erdogan of
Turkey like their Diwan but everybody
knows who's in the g20 just don't why is
he listing
why is he listening country's European
Commission there's levander land
President of the European Council
Charles McHale United Nations
secretary-general Antonio Guterres World
Health Organization director Ted Rose
EDM song world bank president David
Malpass and the International Monetary
Fund managing director Kristalina
Georgieva right so that's a big group
but it's a great group it's and they
were all there every one of them and we
talked about the problem the invisible
skirt won't be a problem for too much
longer the United States is working with
our friends and partners around the
world to stop the spread of the virus
and coordinate our efforts we discussed
how vitally important it is for all of
our nations to immediately share
information and data and we've been
doing that to a large extent but we'll
do it even more so and to inform our I
guess you could say form each of us on
the fight that we've got going one way
the other it's a little bit different
but we're handling it a little bit in
different ways but there is great
uniformity I think we had a it was a
terrific meeting tremendous spirit among
all of those countries you had 20
countries plus the other people that I
mentioned and tremendous spirit
to get this over with after the meeting
with the world leaders I spoke with the
governors of our 50 states and
territories our team has been in
constant communication with the
governors and we had a we had a terrific
meeting somebody in the fake news said
that one of the governor said oh we need
Tom Brady I said yes he meant that in a
positive way he said we need Tom Brady
we're gonna do great and he's meant it
very positively but they took it
differently they think Tom Brady should
be leading the effort why that's only
fake news and I like Tom Brady spoke to
him the other day
he's great what but I wish the news
could be what could be real I wish it
could be honest I wish it weren't
corrupt but so much of it is it's so sad
to see just so sad to say we had a great
meeting I tell you what I'm sure you
have tapes of the meeting I'm sure that
you wear a gift tapes or easily see at
50 governors Plus and maybe your head
tapes you'd see it was really I mean
there's no contention I would say Virgil
you should carry Trump out on on their
shoulders right now one person there was
a little tiny bit of a raising of a
voice a little wise wise guy a little
bit but he's usually a big wise guy not
so much anymore
we saw to it that he wouldn't want how
much anymore but he is we saw to it I
mean I would rate Mike was there a lot
of the folks the back were there and it
was a it was a great meeting took place
at about 12 o'clock so we went from the
g20 to the governor's we also spoke
about the economic relief with the
governors and the package that we're
moving through Congress to deliver much
needed financial assistance to
hardworking families and small
businesses I want to thank Democrats and
Republicans in the Senate for
unanimously passing the largest
financial relief package in American
history 96 to zero and I have to say
it's the largest by far and I'm
profoundly grateful that both parties
came together to provide relief for
American War
kurz and families in this hour of need
the House of Representatives must now
pass this bill hopefully without delay I
think it's got tremendous support when
you're at 96 to nothing and as you know
a couple of those people are quarantined
and one Rand Paul as he's actually got
it
but he'll he'll be betters and he's been
a great guy he's been a great friend of
mine actually got it the massive 2.2
trillion dollar relief package includes
job retention loans for small businesses
with loan forgiveness available for
businesses that keep their workers on
the payroll it's pretty good loan
forgiveness keep the workers on the
payroll it's pretty good
direct cash payments will be available
to American citizens earning less than
ninety nine thousand dollars per year
$3,400 for the typical family of four
expanded unemployment benefits the
average worker who has lost his or her
job will receive 100% of their salary
for up to four full months these are
things that by the way we have plenty
more to go and but they're things that
nobody's ever had any package like this
then and I just want to thank them
hopefully it'll get approved equally
he's talking like we're on the tail end
of this and still not mentioning death
the death toll our case numbers it's
like it's not he doesn't even bring that
up anymore everybody they could be one
vote one vote one grandstander maybe you
might have one grandstander and for that
we'll have to come back and take a
little more time but it'll pass it'll
just take a little longer but let's see
whether or not we have a grandstander
critical support for the hardest-hit
industries with a ban on corporate stock
buybacks and tough new safeguards to
prevent executive compensation abuse
over 100 billion dollars for our amazing
doctors nurses and hospitals
forty five billion dollars for the
disaster relief fund more than doubling
the amount available this is tremendous
stuff twenty seven billion dollars for
the coronavirus response including
sixteen billion dollars to build up the
strategic
national stockpile with critical
supplies including masks respirators and
all sorts of pharmaceuticals 3.5 billion
dollars to expand assistance to child
care providers and child care the
benefits to health care workers first
responders and others on the frontlines
of the crisis and these are really brave
incredible people have to say and some
of them are getting sick and some of
them are getting very sick and some of
them don't even recover they're
incredible people 1 billion dollars for
defense products for cure Minh we are as
you know using the act but we use it
only when necessary
we use it as leverage we generally don't
have to use it to accomplish what we
want to accomplish as of today FEMA has
shipped over 9 million n95 masks 20
million face masks 3.1 million face
shields nearly 6,000 ventilators 2.6
million gowns 14.6 million gloves and
we're sending more every day and we've
got tremendous amounts of equipment
coming in a lot of great companies are
making equipment right now the
ventilators obviously they take a little
longer to make but we have a lot of
companies making them and we're gonna be
in great shape we took over an empty
shelf we took over a very depleted place
in a lot of ways in you imagine as you
know the testing is going very very well
why and that was obsolete and broken and
we fixed it and it's been going really
good all lives and I think very
importantly the the stockpile we're
really filling it up and we fill it up
rapidly but we they're filling the
stockpile you got to get the stockpile
out to people and again the state has to
be doing this kind of a thing also we're
sort of a we look we look from behind a
little bit and we look at how are they
doing and if they need help we do it but
it's their first responsibility
sometimes they just can't get it but we
load it up and we send it out but if we
can we have it sent directly to the
state
wanted to go directly to the point where
we want it I can now announce something
that I think is incredible what they've
done in the Navy because the incredible
naval hospital ship the USNS comfort
which is incredible actually when you
see it inside will be underway to New
York City on Saturday right
so it's going to be leaving on Saturday
rather than three weeks from now they
did the maintenance quickly and it was
gonna be there for quite a while longer
another three or four weeks and it
should be arriving I told the governor
20 minutes ago Governor Cuomo that the
ship will be arriving at New York Harbor
on Monday I think I'm going to go out
and I'll kiss it goodbye I'll go I'll go
too
it's in Virginia as you know and I will
go and will be waving together because I
suspect it means you need to stay at the
White House we following John you're
gonna be following maybe you know great
ship it's a great vessels right so if
you want to go I'll see you there and if
you think serious guys after being fully
loaded with medical supplies it's gonna
be it's loaded up to the top and it's
over at the door for naval base that's
where it departs it is expected then to
we're saving about three to four weeks
by the incredible work done by the Navy
as if what they need in trying to launch
this thing quickly is the president's
motorcade there right it go the ship
will arrive and I believe it's gonna get
a little bit of a ceremony it's just
something very beautiful about its
incredible piece of work gonna be
landing at Pier 90 in Manhattan to
provide hospital surge capacity for the
New York metropolitan area so it's a
surge capacity they may use it for this
or they may have other people coming in
from hospitals unrelated to the virus
and then they'll use those hospitals on
land they'll use those hospital for the
virus
we'll see how they do it they could you
do it either way one way or the other
whichever one is best but it could be
because it's set up so well for a
regular Hospital that they may take
people out of hospitals and then use
those rooms for the virus the virus is
in the private sector working closely
with the FDA continue to collaborate to
discover and test treatments and
therapies that can effectively reduce
the duration and symptoms of the virus
and help very much help people to
recover and I'm firmly committed to
bringing these treatments to market very
quickly we have a we have a lot of tests
going on with regard to different
medicines yeah
and I hope I hope we get lucky I hope we
hit a lot of talented scientists and
doctors are working on therapeutics a
cure the vaccines I think we're doing
very well many exciting new products for
coronavirus customers are on the way
but to the vaccines I think we're doing
well with regard to a lot of the things
I just mentioned but we'll have to see
what happens well there know fairly soon
about a lot of them but it's very
advanced and the vaccines are very
advanced prior to as you know a fairly
reasonably long test period of in that
case over a year every American should
be proud of the incredible spirit our
country has brought to this effort it's
been incredible citizens from all walks
of life have come together to turn the
tide in this battle we're witnessing the
extraordinary power of American unity
like a lot of people have never seen
even getting a vote you're talking about
trillions of dollars and you get a vote
of 96 to nothing we are waging war on
this virus using every financial
scientific medical pharmaceutical and
military resource to halt its spread and
protect our citizens I want to express
our tremendous thanks to the American
people for continuing to practice social
distancing like you people are
practicing right here it's I don't know
this room may never be the same
yeah you can tell which things are not
on the piece of paper and follow
government
lines vice-president pence lifts up that
card every time and it's not very
complicated but hopefully you can do
that and your commitment will make all
the difference in the world and that's
one of the big ones will be for a while
stay home just relax stay home making a
lot of progress as we continue to gather
more information and accelerate the
testing where we're doing record numbers
of tests now far more than any other
country is not per capita I told you
yesterday eight days here because you
heard so much about South Korea there
the media kept talking about Korea South
Korea we have a great relationship with
president moon and South Korea but when
I hear so much about South Korea so in
eight days in eight days we do more
testing than they did in eight weeks and
it's a very highly sophisticated test
the best test we'll be able to deploy
even more data-driven and targeted
approaches to slow the ultimately you
know it's a very devastating thing but
we will vanquish this virus vanquish a
lot of progress has been made that's why
earlier today I said a letter to
America's governors describing how we
will be using the data to update
existing guidance on social distancing
which will be developed in close
coordination with our nation's public
health officials and scientists because
of the sacrifices of our great doctors
and nurses and healthcare professionals
the brilliance of our scientists and
researchers and the goodness and
generosity of our people I know that we
will achieve victory and quickly return
to the path of exceptional health safety
and prosperity for all of our citizens
we have to get back to work our people
want to work I'll go back they have to
go back and we're gonna be talking about
dates we're gonna be talking with a lot
of great professionals but this is a
country that was built on
getting it done and our people want to
go work I'm hearing I'm hearing it loud
and clear from everybody
so we'll see what what happens we're
gonna have a lot more information early
next week and we'll be reporting that
back but I just want to leave it with
you we have to go back this is the
United States of America they don't want
to sit around and wait and they'll be
practicing and by the way a lot of
people misinterpret when I say go back
they're going to be practicing as much
as you can social distancing and washing
your hands and not shaking hands and all
of the things that we talked about so
much but they have to go back to work
our country has to go back our country
is based on that yeah and I think it's
gonna happen pretty quickly I think it's
gonna happen pretty quickly a lot of
progress is made but we got to go back
to work we may take sections of our
country we may take large sections of
our country that aren't so seriously
affected and we may do it that way but
we've got to start the process pretty
soon so we'll be talking to you a little
bit more about that next week
and with that if you have any questions
you could ask and then I'm no one else I
suppose on stay behind and he's going to
take questions and also introduce some
of the people you could ask them some
questions John please numbers out 3.3
million yeah I think it's not a surprise
well it's nobody's fault certainly not
in this country nobody's fault we got
very lucky when we made a decision not
to allow people in from China at a very
early date I say that because some
people has nothing to do with the bus
route accept it but this was a great
decision made by our country or there's
the numbers that you're talking about
we're a big country there'd be you're
far greater far far bigger so when I
heard the number I mean I heard it could
be six million could be seven million
well there's still time
that was last three or 3.2
but it's a lot of jobs but I think we'll
come back very strong the sooner we get
back to work you know every day that we
stay out it gets harder to bring it back
very quickly and our people don't want
to stay out so I I know those numbers
jump but I think you'll see a very fast
turnaround once we have a victory over
the the hidden enemy as I say invisible
scourge sometimes a hidden enemy is a
lot tougher than somebody that stares
you in the face right so we'll see what
happens but I mean they're fully
expected numbers at least I mean at
least a place well we have very strong
deployments on the southern border as
you know with Mexico and we had some
troops up in Canada but I'll find out
about that I guess it's equal justice to
a certain extent but in Canada we have
we do have troops equal justice on the
border you know we have a lot of things
coming in from Canada we have trade some
illegal trade that we don't like we have
very strong sanctions on some we have
very strong tariffs on dumping steel and
we don't like steel coming through our
border that's been dumped right in
Canada so they can avoid the tariffs
unite charge a lot of tariffs for the
steel and it's been great for our steel
companies because now they can really go
you look at what's happened with steel
it's been pretty incredible but we've
taken in billions and billions of
dollars in tariffs on steel and much of
it comes in from China but they can come
through the Canadian border she still
doesn't understand how tariffs work
United States now surpassed China is the
country with the highest number of no I
think it's a tribute to our testing you
know number one you don't know what the
numbers are in China Janet tells your
numbers and I'm speaking to President Xi
tonight I believe we'll have a good
conversation I'm sure but you just don't
know you know what are the numbers but I
think it's a tribute to the testing
beautiful conversation I call him a liar
numbers of people and every day the way
the system works and I want to thank
especially Roche has been fantastic
great company
he's a progenitor tremendous role chevre
was telling me before that they were
really they've really stepped up to the
plate and done great as have other of
the companies but it seems that they're
really roguish particularly well so I
see what happens there but it's a
tribute to the amount of testing that
would we're doing tremendous testing and
I'm sure you're not able to tell what
China is testing I said some people were
projecting that would be six or seven
and it's I believe 3.3 million Americans
out of work 3.3 was for last week the
projection was one point six so Trump's
talking about total unemployment that
these are just last week and the numbers
were double the projection so I'm trying
to keep up with the fact-checking here I
mean the things I just read to you are
being considered and other things are
being considered people are going to be
getting big checks and it's not their
fault what happened to them is not their
fault so we're doing we're doing a lot
of different things on health insurance
we have meetings on it today
we're taking care of our people this is
not their fault what happened and we're
taking care we're starting off by
sending them very big checks I think for
a family of four it's about $3,000 and
we're taking care of our people were
taking care of our workers this was not
you know as I say this was on a
financial crisis this was a health
crisis of medical crisis medical
take care of our people as police yeah
the part about the virus starts soon
with a survey about this morning saying
that 3 percent of all restaurants in
this country have shuttered for good it
has three weeks and the projection is
that 11 percent more our colony closed
in the next 30 days so what do you say
to a restaurant owner who is looking at
his sheets and thinks he has to close
well I hate to I know the business very
well I understand the restaurant
business is a very delicate business
it's a business that that it's not easy
you know I always say in a restaurant
business you can serve 30 great meals to
a person or a family and they love it
one bad meal number 31 they never come
back again it's a very tough business
but they're great people that run
restaurants and I've heard 3% could be
lost and you could go as high as 10 or
11% but they'll all come back in one
form or another it might be a different
restaurant but it's gonna be a great
business for a lot of people and we're
making it easy for people to look what
we're doing what we're doing in terms of
loans what we're doing in terms of
salaries they'll all come back it may
not be the same restaurant it may not be
the same ownership but they'll all be
back
yes sir please pledges from American
companies provide supplies
yes we top 81 thousand cases in the US
does it make sense to relook at using
the defense production Act well I talked
about the defense production Act a lot
and I've you know I've enacted it I so
understand that that the US Chamber of
Commerce has been lobbying Trump not to
use it and so far he's been listening we
could withdraw but for the most part the
companies we don't need it we say we
need this and they say don't bother
we're gonna do it I mean we we're
dealing with for General Motors 3m we're
deal with great companies they want to
do this they want to do this they're
doing things that that frankly they
don't need somebody to walk over there
with a with a hammer and say do it they
are getting it done
would that making tremendous amounts of
equipment tremendous amounts and when
this is over we're gonna be fully
stockpiled which they would have never
been except for a circumstance this was
this was something that nobody has ever
thought could happen to this country I'm
not even blaming look we inherited a
broken situation but while he blames
Obama today we learned that the Obama
administration literally handed to Trump
a 69 page color-coded book called
pandemic preparedness and how to deal
with a pandemic
okay he's insisting who knew this could
happen maybe that frightens him a little
bit you know it's got tremendous power
but I haven't had to please my
colleagues or social distancing trying
to get in the first question has to do
with cruise liners like carnival I'm
brilliant
they want this really page but they're
worried because they offshore
like Panama Liberia they might not
qualify central Polly has said that they
should move back to the United States
before they get a check do you agree
should they pay US taxes to get US
taxpayer relief so I'm a big fan of
Senator Hawley and I also like the idea
there were some senators that didn't
want to do anything like Carnival great
company but they're based in different
places I won't tell you why I could tell
you exactly where they're based but I
won't do that with Google but they're
based in actually more than one places
you know ships are register to different
locations
I do like the concept of perhaps coming
in and registering here coming into the
United States it's you know it's very
tough to make a loan to a company when
they're based in a different country but
with that being said they have thousands
and thousands of people that work there
and maybe almost as importantly that
work on shore filling these ships with
Goods and products and the cruise line
business is very important and I know
Carnival what a great job they do Micky
Arison and I would think that we could
stick with Senator Holly and maybe
really look at that very seriously we
might very strongly look at it but we're
not gonna do it they can keep the boats
registered elsewhere to avoid taxes will
still cut them checks number of people
outside of the ship itself I mean you
look you look at these ports it's loaded
up with shops and and and people that
are involved with the ship so we're
gonna work very hard on the cruise line
business and we're gonna try and work
something out but I like the concept
yeah sir the Senate bill includes Abe is
directly tied to the airlines and
since before the pandemic Boeing was
already suffering from the losses of 737
airplanes do you think it's appropriate
to use this legislation to sort of
provide them with seventeen billion
dollars of a on top of you know 25
billion that they could qualify for as a
passenger airline than another four
billion that they could qualify for a
cargo airline is that bad so the airline
business is a very tough business over
many years it's been very very tough
it's got everything it's got labor it's
got very strong powerful you know you
look at the cost of these airliners
everything is tough very highly
technological you look at how
complicated how complex
it's got unions it's got everything the
airline business somehow the plane stays
up I mean you got to get the plane
everything we just don't know business
with that being said we have to keep our
airlines going and we're going to be
using some now maybe we'll take a piece
of the airline's for the country for a
country where we loan money and we take
a piece of it's all fully ready we're
ready to go
but if we didn't do that we'd end up
with no Airlines and we can't do that
the airline business is very vital to
our country it's a tough business we
have to understand that so not I mean I
could tell you other businesses that are
different kinds of business they are
very good businesses but airlines have
always been very very tough please yeah
I didn't call you a cold just gentleman
he seems to be deliberately not going to
CNN by the way I don't know if you
noticed I'm with Bloomberg yes Mario
part Michael good
mr. president on Monday did you speak
with Chinese President gee before you
urged Americans to not blame Asian
Americans for the coronavirus we notice
that she's backed off their language I
know you're speaking with no idea I'm
speaking to him tonight it's scheduled
to go tonight I'll have a call with
President Xi of China very good
relationship no I didn't like when they
came up and it wasn't him somebody at a
lower level mid-level we found out
pretty much but they made a statement
that our soldiers brought it into China
came from China
and you know we just signed a very big
deal with China they're paying us a lot
of money in tariffs remember the
question was why are you no longer
calling it the Chinese virus take
advantage of the United States until I
came here with sleepy Joe Biden and
Obama and Bush and everybody else I'm
not blaming them I'm blaming everybody
they were allowed to 500 billion dollars
a year they were taken out we had trade
deficits that were so large nobody's
ever seen anything like it
question was why'd you stop calling it
the Chinese virus you said look but now
we're taking and billions of dollars and
we gave some to our farmers because
China you know they targeted our farmers
and our farmers are very happy and and
our farmers got through a very rough
period because of what I was able to do
took the money from China and gave it to
the farmers and we had plenty left over
after that now we're going into a Phase
two negotiation with China but we're
getting 25% on two hundred and fifty
billion dollars and the question was
why'd you stop calling it the Chinese
virus sure that so we've never had to
deal with China that China took
advantage of the United States and you
know what I don't blame China for that I
blame the people that were right here
because they should have never allowed
it to happen but the relationship with
China has been a very good one John
question was why just stop calling it
the Chinese virus
never asked me to calm it down somebody
might have spoken to somebody but nobody
spoke to me about it someone spoke to
someone because you know I talk about
the Chinese virus and and I mean it
that's what came from you know if you
look at Ebola if you got all a Lyme
right Lyme Connecticut you look at all
these different horrible diseases they
seem to come with the name with the
location and this was the Chinese virus
it's back but I don't have to say it if
they feel so strongly about it we'll see
but you know we have we just made a
great deal with China right hopefully
for both parties but we made a deal with
China I'm gonna do another one I looks
like maybe they wouldn't do it very
badly
maybe they'll want to wait like Iran
they want to wait to see whether or not
Trump gets beaten in the election
because would they love to negotiate
with the Biden or somebody else other
than me they would love it that's the
best dream in the world so many others
so there are some that maybe a you know
waiting until after November third the
election day but I think we're doing
very well it would be sad if we blew all
of the advantages that we had because
we've made unbelievable trade deals
whether it's Mexico Canada Japan South
Korea China and others shine we have we
have changed the whole thing around
please today you said a notification
letter to the nation's governor's saying
he's got to Roberts twice he still
hasn't gone to Caitlyn Collins from CNN
once and other items do you have any
data yet to suggest which specific areas
of the country may have their guidelines
relaxed which areas that the country may
have their guidelines I think Debra will
talk to you about that and Tony in a few
minutes but I think we'll start talking
about that because we have to open up we
can't say let's close people don't want
to close John I say it again and again
the reason I do because I want you to
report it eventually go ahead Steve go
ahead
yes still not going to be able to talk
yeah it's his call I mean I'll talk to
him whatever he wants to I mean you know
we'll have I think a very fruitful call
I have a good call
tonight at 9 o'clock please yes we'll be
talking about that yeah we'll be talking
about the virus in the back Thank You
mr. president I'm just by the jobless
claims numbers today no crazy yeah
except over 4,000 points the last three
days again record
yeah the largest chart since 1931 do you
think that the economic uncertainty has
passed on the sort committee no not yet
it hasn't passed but it's come a long
way I think they think we're doing a
really good job in terms of running this
whole situation having to do with the
divorce I think they feel that I think
they feel the administration myself and
the administration are doing a good job
with people keeping very importantly
people informed because it was a great
fear and a lot of good things are
happening the mortality rate is and in
my opinion you have to speak to Deborah
Tony all of the others but in my opinion
it's way way down and that takes a lot
of fear out you know it's one thing to
have it it's another thing to die you
know when I first got involved I was
being told numbers that were much much
higher than the number that seems to be
and remember that people that have it
many people have it I just spoke to two
people they had it they never went to a
doctor they had it absolutely had it but
they never went to a doctor they never
went to anything they didn't report it
you have thousands and hundreds of
thousands of cases like that so you have
to add that to the caseload also so he's
admitting that we have hundreds of
thousands okay.i that percentages is a
much lower percentage than I ever
thought that's one of the reasons I say
look we're going to beat this and we're
going to get back to work
yes please this race
the DOJ announced charges against
nicolas maduro for drug trafficking big
does anything that they know generally
it's also expected there's Venezuela's
gonna get him really hard by the
coronavirus does the administration is
suing Allah a weak point we don't look
at or there's a serious problem for over
a hundred and fifty nations the virus I
would say this Maduro and Venezuela
we're watching it very closely we'll see
what happens but that is correct those
charges were made please we will give
you that notification we'll let you know
okay question about classifying four
counties a lot of these areas have not
done testing yet is it safe to say that
the current guidelines will be extended
into next week
will you will you wait to change those
guidelines until you have the I want
those guidelines to go even when we're
open and fully operational and frankly
much of the guidelines like shaking
hands maybe people aren't gonna be shaky
and Hansen he wants taking hands you
know Tony had mentioned to me Tony foul
cheese the other day that I don't think
he was would be too upset with the
concept of not shaking hands he was
saying that the flu would cut down the
regular fluidly cut down by the
handshakes if we didn't do that if we
didn't shake hands you know the regular
flu of which you know you have a lot of
deaths and a lot of problems with that
too so I think a lot of a lot of great
things are gonna but when we're open
just say just a few when we're open as
soon as we open that doesn't mean you're
gonna stop with the guidelines you'll
still try and distance yourself maybe
not to the same extent because you have
to lead a life but I think the time is
coming how about one more question go
ahead in the back Nora CNN literally
I also have two questions because I
asked him on behalf before impress as
well so one domestic question one
international domestically you just
tweeted the other day saying that it's
very important that we totally protect
Asian Americans yes I did very important
to me but still really very important to
me they have to we have to protect our
Asian Americans it's very it's a very
important that was a very important
tweet to me I didn't like things that I
was hearing please really like that
what's what's what's the concrete
measure
I don't know all I know is this daddy
can't tell you Asian Americans are a
country doing fantastically well I'm
almost of them as you know and they're
doing fantastically well again but I did
want to put that statement out to social
media stay here to God because to me
agent Americans a great part of our
country thank you all very much we'll
see you soon thank you ignoring CNN I
can hear caitlin collins yelling up at
him and off he goes well good afternoon
everyone
the coronavirus task force new yeah
White House coronavirus task force met
today we continue to move okay so let's
this is mute pence for a little bit just
so I can get caught up on stuff you see
Caitlin Collins sitting here and of
course she's now texting someone he
literally just ignored me the entire
time didn't call on her clearly clearly
a sign that he is very very angry let me
just get new member thank-yous out of
the way to get caught up
Douglas McCloud is new member number 10
sorry 10 not 19 AAA oh is new member
number 11 Carolyn Walker's new member
number 12
Debbie handy is new member number 13
also want to say thanks to Ryan laugh
ler who's new member number 14 Jonathan
Lynx is new member number 15 Pablo
Cuellar is new member number 16
Carol skippering is new member number 17
I know I missed a few but I'll get back
to them best way to support the streams
of course daily is a grab a membership
at join pakman.com I do people want to
hear
Pence's daily thing or do we want to
wait wait a little bit until we hear
from dr. foul Chi and
dr. Burks because we've got just a ton
of questions from people a lot of thank
yous coming in via super chat Ken Dayle
says voices like yours are important
David I very much appreciate that maybe
we want maybe if pence holds up the
PowerPoint we go to that I don't know
it's just very hard to say but I think
we kind of have a sense Pippen says the
exact same thing every day
Jeremy Comfort says I'm autistic thank
you for keeping me calm my pleasure
appalled Burbridge says thanks David for
the great work you do elements of
medical says my new screen name I love
that elements of medical mascot says I
turned out I tuned out are we talking
about the virus yet we you know at some
point in this Trump did mention the
virus that's true
but but you know I satirical symphony
says NPR Seattle isn't broadcasting
these anymore yeah I read that you know
I think that the right thing to do is to
broadcast them but fact check them as
best we can that's the effort that I
make and I know that different people
have different perspectives on that but
I that's that's my preference thanks to
I plugs and Navarez and I am comp you
bear let's go back and listen to pence a
little bit too I'm sure talking about 15
days to stop the spread 550 mm tests
have been performed and completed all
across the United States we want to
thank the American Hospital Association
and hospitals across the country that
are just now beginning to report in a
fulsome way the results of those tests
and when the president signs the law
tomorrow will actually be required by
law but as dr. Burks and dr. pouchy have
explained many times at this podium it's
so important that any hospital or any
lab that's doing testing report back to
the CDC and FEMA so we have full
visibility right now to provide the
president with the very best counsel
good news today on testing Abbott
Laboratories submitted to the FDA today
a request for approval of a
point-of-care test this would be the
kind of test where you could go to your
doctor you could get the test done there
at your doctor
and have the results in no more than 15
minutes dr. Steve Hahn will be here
tomorrow to talk about progress in
evaluating Abbott Laboratories
point-of-care tests also speaking of the
FDA on the subject of swabs the FDA did
announce earlier this week that testing
symptomatic patients by swabbing from
the front of the nose is perfectly
appropriate and it's already begun
across the country it allows for self
collection and it also relieves the
burden on healthcare protection it saves
it saves personal protective equipment
from being expended when people can
administer a test themselves and dr.
Burks will speak about the importance
and the availability of swabs with
regard to supplies you heard the
president speak about what we have
already shipped out from the National
strategic stockpile more than 9 million
n95 masks for healthcare workers 20
million surgical masks 6,000 ventilators
you know we had a lot of stuff shipped
out we rarely hear about the shipments
being received which is weird to me with
a number of suppliers to manufacture
ventilators even while we work with
state leaders to assess not just what
ventilators are available in their state
hospitals but what ventilators are
available in private hospitals across
their state and governors across the
country are are doing great work
evaluating the full supply of tens of
thousands of ventilators that are
available let me also say thank you to
the American Society of
Anesthesiologists and dr. Mary Peterson
the American Society of
Anesthesiologists actually produced a
video tomorrow they will host a webinar
for healthcare workers to demonstrate
how the devices that anesthesiologists
use can be very easily converted into a
ventilator that's appropriate for a
patient's struggling with respiratory
ailment like the corona virus and we're
very grateful this actually adds tens of
thousands of devices to the supply and
we're all truly grateful to dr. Peterson
and the whole Association for their
full cooperation with five of ten
counties in the country being the top
counties for coronavirus being in the
New York City metropolitan area let us
reiterate our recommendation that that
any resident of the Greater New York
City area who has traveled elsewhere in
the United States please check your
temperature mind your health and self
isolate for 14 days what we don't want
again with five of the top ten counties
for coronavirus being in the Greater New
York City area we don't want anyone and
no one would want to inadvertently carry
the corona virus to a community or to a
family member inadvertently because
they've come out of that community so
again as dr. Fauci said recently if you
come out of New York over the last
several weeks before the mitigation
measures are put into effect in
particularly weird check your
temperature mind your health and self
isolate for 14 days it is inspiring as I
prepared to introduce dr. Burch to talk
about the data that we're monitoring on
a regular basis and about you talk about
mitigation let me conclude by saying how
inspiring it is to see the way America
and the American people are responding
to this moment we all were awakened this
morning with record unemployment numbers
not unexpected during the time of
national crisis that we are facing but
what you may not know is that while
there were some three million plus new
unemployment claims Walmart announced
they're hiring 150,000 new associates
through the end of May Amazon a few
weeks back announced they're hiring a
hundred thousand additional warehouse
employees to meet a growing demand at
Amazon for online purchases CVS health
is going to provide bonuses to their
employees working with patients and hire
3.3 million lost their jobs but there
will be 250,000 temps hired so you know
you do the math bees and that's just a
short summary of a list the totals
almost a half a million jobs that have
been announced by businesses
around America and it's not just been
about jobs it's been about generosity an
Heiser Bush is making a five million
dollar donation to the American Red
Cross to support first responders Ohio
hotels is offering doctors and nurses
and first responders free rooms at any
of their 300 hotels all across America
and the pharmaceutical company AbbVie is
actually donating 25 million dollars to
the International Medical Corps and to
feeding America American businesses are
stepping up to partner with us to meet
this moment but they're being incredibly
generous as well to all of those that
are stepping in great ways and providing
health care services and of course to
those most in need we can do this
America but it'll take all of us it's
the president often says we're all in
this together
but as millions of Americans do their
part with 15 days to slow the spread
putting into practice the president's
guidelines for combating the corona
virus and its spread we grow more
confident every day that this too shall
pass with the cooperation and generosity
and prayers money every day it gets
worse
and every day they're more confident
that it's almost over I mean in a sense
every day we're a day closer to the end
but it's gonna get worse before it gets
better
and now for information on the latest on
data and what we're seeing for actual
information we're gonna bring a doctor
up here Thank You mr. vice president so
just as a summary of where it looks
domestically I won't talk so much about
the global issues at this time we do
have 19 out of our 50 states to be
reminded that had early cases but have
persistently low level of cases and at
this point have less than 200 cases so
that's almost 40% of the country with
extraordinarily low numbers and they are
testing some of our governors have been
very adamant about their need for test
kits we have gotten them test kits when
we had Abbot add about a week ago to the
test kits we've been able to open up
additional test kits for cont for states
that want to do surveillance and want to
do contact tracing these 19 states are
doing still active
tainment there at 200 cases despite the
fact that they've been measuring them
over the last three to four weeks still
though 55% of all cases and 55% of all
new cases continue out of the New York
at New York metro area that's the New
Jersey part and New York part in
particular I haven't added in
Connecticut or other counties at this
point we are concerned about certain
counties that look like they're having a
more rapid increase when you look at
Wayne County in Michigan and you look at
Cook County in Chicago so we have
integrated all of our information to not
only look at where the cases are today
about how they're moving so we can alert
FEMA to where we think the next
potential hotspot is all of the counties
that I've mentioned the hot spots are in
urban areas or in the communities that
serve that urban area and I think that's
something very important to remember as
we move forward because of the
innovations within our private sector we
continue to have these new platforms
added for laboratory testing and these
become critical platforms for states
that have very low rates and very low
rates needed to test why is that
important some of these machines have
wells and plastic plates that in order
to be effective you have to put on about
almost 96 samples and others are made
for four samples or 24 samples at a time
so what's critical for us to be able to
do is to match the need to the county
and state and that's the role that we
can provide advice on because we get to
see across the whole country and where
those items are needed most and so this
is allowing us to adapt and adopt really
allocation of tests or recommendations
to state of what piece of equipment they
may need the 5500 50,000 tests you can
do the math but we're still running
somewhere about 14 percent overall that
means 86 percent of the people with
significant symptoms because remember
you had to have a fever and symptoms to
get tested at this point
so still 86% are negative these are
really important facts for the American
people I'm sure many of you saw the
recent report out of the UK about them
adjusting completely their needs this is
really quite important if you remember
that was the report that said there
would be five hundred thousand deaths in
the UK and 2.2 million deaths in the
United States they've adjusted that
number in the UK to twenty thousand so
half a million to twenty thousand we're
looking into this in great detail to
understand that adjustment I'm gonna say
something that's a little bit
complicated but I'm gonna try to do it
in a way that nobody will understand it
together because she thinks because if
from anything either you have to have a
large group of people who are
asymptomatic who've never presented for
any tests in order to have the kind of
numbers that were predicted right to get
to sixty million people infected or of
six million people infected you have to
have a large group of asymptomatic
because in no country to date have we
seen an attack rate over one in a
thousand so either we're only measuring
the tip of the iceberg symptomatic cases
and underneath it are a large group of
people so we're working very hard to get
that antibody test because that's a good
way to figure out who are all these
people under here and do they exist need
that or we have the transmission
completely wrong so these are the things
we're looking at because the predictions
of the models don't match the dodgy
thinking that that's too complicated for
people that's how we've been dumbed down
by this presidency where she's like I
might speak a little too complex
literally so if we were Italy and you
did all those divisions Italy should
have close to 400,000 deaths they're not
close to achieving that so these are the
kinds of things we're trying to
understand models or models we're
adapting now to the rillette there's
enough data now of the real experience
with the coronavirus
the ground to really make these
predictions much more sound so when
people start talking about 20% of a
population getting infected it's very
scary but we don't have data that
matches that based on the experience and
then finally the situation about
ventilators we were reassured and
meeting with our colleagues in New York
that there are still ICU beds remaining
and there's still significant over a
thousand or 2,000 ventilators that have
not been utilized yet please for the
reassurance of people around the world
to wake up this morning and look at
people talking about creating DNR
situations do not resuscitate situations
for patients there is no situation in
the United States right now that
warrants that kind of discussion you can
be thinking about it in a hospital
certainly many hospitals talk about this
on a daily basis but to say that to the
American people to make the implication
that when they need a hospital bed it's
not going to be there or when they need
that ventilator it's not going to be
there we don't have an evidence of that
right now and it's our job collectively
to assure the American people that it's
our collective job to make sure that
doesn't happen right now you can see the
state these cases are concentrated and
hi guys how much better is this one
Trump leaves the room and the doctors
get to just talk is it I mean it's just
so much better other parts of New York
State that don't have any infections
right now so we can be creative we can
meet the need by being responsive but
there's no model right maybe totally
lying but it's better be on the ground
where we can see that 60 to 70 percent
of Americans are going to get infected
in the next 8 to 12 weeks I just want to
be clear about that so we're adapting to
the reality on the ground we're looking
at the models of how they can inform but
we also are learning very clearly from
South Korea and from Italy and from
Spain just a final cuz I know many of
you will look up my numbers the only
people who are over really one in a
thousand cases are
people that have very small populations
like Monaco and Liechtenstein so you
will see a different number coming from
when your population is really tiny one
case can put you over one to a thousand
or two to a thousand thank you ouchy
Thank You mr. vice president I'm gonna
change the topic just a little bit
because there was a questions that came
up and I've been asked about this and a
couple of media interactions regarding
the interventions that we're talking
about and it's important because it's
about something that I said yesterday
about what we would likely see whenever
you put the clamps down and shut things
down you do it for two reasons
you do it to prevent the further spread
just be called mitigation but you also
do it to buy yourself time to get better
prepared for it might be a rebound it
may be a rebound that we get things
really under control and then you pull
back which ultimately we're gonna have
to do everybody in the world is gonna
have to do that you're either gonna get
a rebound or it might cycle into the
next season so what are we gonna do to
prepare ourselves for that one of the
most important things is one that I
mentioned several times from this podium
and that is to clarify a bit about the
timeline for vaccines and would that
have any real impact on what we would
call the rebound or what we would call a
cycling in the season right certainly
for sure a vaccine is not gonna help us
now next month the month after but as I
mentioned to you we went into a phase
one trial and I keep referring to one
vaccine there's more than one there's a
couple of handfuls of vaccines at
different stages of development but
they're all following the same course
and the course is your first go in to a
phase one trial to see if it's safe and
you have very few people forty-five
people within a certain age group all
healthy none at really any great risk of
getting infected right the reason you do
that because you want to make sure that
it's safe then the next thing you do and
that takes about three months easily
maybe more so that's gonna bring us into
the beginning of middle of the summer
then you go to a Phase two trial or what
we say to three which means we're going
to put a lot of people in there
now we hope that there aren't a lot of
people getting infected but it is likely
there will be somewhere in the world
where that's going on yes so it's likely
that we will get what's called an
efficacy signal and we will know whether
or not it actually works if in fact it
does we hope to rush it to be able to
have some impact on recycling in the
next season and like I said that could
be a year to a year and a half I'm not
changing any of the dates that I
mentioned but one of the things that we
are gonna do that you need to understand
that has been a stumbling block for
previous development of vaccines right
and that is even before you know
something works at risk you have to
start producing it because once you know
it works you can't say great it works
now give me another six months to
produce it so we're working with a
variety of companies I'm seeing probably
take that risk
we didn't take it with Zika that's why
you know we have a nice Zika vaccine but
we don't have enough to do it because
there's no Zika around same with soccers
so that's one of the things we're really
gonna push on is to be able to have it
ready if in fact it works now the issue
of safety something that I want to make
sure the American public understand it's
not only safety when you inject somebody
and they get maybe an idiosyncratic
reaction they get a little allergic
reaction they get pain their safety
associated does the vaccine make you
worse and there are diseases in which
you vaccinate someone they get infected
with what you're trying to protect them
with and you actually enhance the
infection right you can get a good feel
for that in animal models so that's
gonna be interspersed at the same time
that we're testing we're gonna try and
make sure we don't have enhancement it's
the worst possible thing you could do is
vaccinate somebody to prevent infection
and actually make them worse next and
finally we're gonna get you to your
question finally with regard to
therapies I mean we keep getting asked
about therapies there's a whole menu of
therapies that are going into clinical
trial as I've told you all and are
repeated again the best way to get the
best drug as
quickly as possible is to do a
randomized controlled trial so that you
know is it safe effective if it's not
effective get it off the board and go to
the next thing if it is effective get it
out to the people that need it so you're
gonna be hearing over the next month or
more about different drugs that are
gonna go into these randomized
controlled trials and I feel confident
knowing about what this virus is and
what we can do with it that we will have
some sort of therapy that give at least
a partial if not a very good protection
in in preventing progression of disease
Wow we'll be back here talking about
that a lot I'm sure thank you guys I am
now officially an authoritarian foul
gist okay make that spread spread the
word like I mentioned I have a heart out
at 6:30 I've got a run I will stream
again tomorrow thanks to everybody
joining me pick up the questions on
somebody else's